i'm really really really happy you have
uh sasha as guru gives the first talk
today
i've heard it before and it's beautiful
so
you speakers today hardly need
any introduction but um just to mention
one of the
main things separate borrow was famous
for being one of the few people who
proved
overbound original overbounds bounds
for monotone circuits
he had done beautiful
working bounded arithmetic and the
proof complexity in bounded territory
class
last friday we talked about uh
rsuv isomorphism for example
and um
he's also well known for uh
probably the most important barrier
result in circuit complexion also
bounded there is making the natural
proof
area and hopefully you might hear a bit
about it today
in addition to that uh done some
quantum complexity communication
complexity some other complexity and
some
deep mathematics uh
like algebras um
he uh unsurprisingly got numerous prices
for that
uh just to mention the global price for
the very results for natural proofs
and i think and even nina's price for
circuit lower bounds
there is nothing much to say but uh i'd
rather let you speak for himself so
please
the floor all right
thank you very much tonya for the nice
introduction again
uh if you want to ask questions please
unmute yourself
and ask highly preferred method so and
uh first of all uh this october will be
highly speculative
and so er it is i apologize that it's
about
uh some somewhat old stuff uh i will
talk here at simon's
i mean virtual talk somewhere in my in
my
more modern things and
another apology i
already made is that some of you
or many of you have seen this dog before
a longer version of it but i still hope
i made a few changes all right so we'll
start with our favorite program p
versus np i think at this point in the
game
everyone here knows what it is but
we are going to tweak this question a
bit
so the first version we may ask
and that's how it was or
attract people try to attack it's or
it's or in this form
it's a slightly stronger version and
it's asking whether languages in np have
polynomial size circuits let me remind
you that p slash party is anything or is
non-uniform
p which means everything you can compute
where it's polynomial size circuits
so then we can further relax this
question
and ask are there any explicit boolean
functions not in b slash polar which
explicit being in good old sense
in mathematical sense not necessary and
pure something
which you would recognize as explicit
and so then we may ask this question
which looks ridiculous what's
uh as we will see it is not at least for
the purposes of my talk today
and so this question is
[Music]
this our question is uh actually
uh even more relaxed version are there
any boolean functions that cannot be
computed by
polynomial size circuits well of course
i have put here a question mark but
of course we all know that it is the
case it's classical result by shannon
somewhat uh clarified by lupanov
later and it says that
it is indeed the keys and we have
functions and
actually almost all functions are hard
so here are some notations here of fn is
the circuit size
of my function f in some standard basis
so almost all of them are are
exponential almost all functions are
exponential and that's
basically the on the whole parameter
it's a simple application of the pitch
on whole principle
but let's look closer at this proof so
what's really going on is that if you
want to run this argument
then you are wants to be able to count
really well
and by really well i mean you are going
to be able to count
really large numbers so you want to
count up to
double exponential psi bubble or double
exponent
in the number of variables because it's
the overall number of your boolean
functions or at least up to this
number but still you have to count
really a lot
and that's uh that will be the main
theme
in my talk today is that actual uh
right the main principle is what you can
do
depends on how well you can count
right so maybe you should use it in k-12
education
in our or classes
on arithmetic but that's really that
will be the divide incline
everything will depend on what is the
maximal number you can see in your
arguments
and you can count output that number
so let me now revisit this question
are there any boolean functions not in p
slash polynomial
and for the purposes of my talk first of
all we are going to
be interested in proof theory
so we are going to study whether this
equation is probable
somewhere or not or
using some class of methods and
uh if i if there are any logicians here
or group theorists then we will
understand
for the purposes of this talk where we
will understand specie area
slightly more broadly it's not
necessarily first order here
or prepositional here it's something
that some class of methods
that you can rigorously define
uh that's uh that word you don't
compromise on
it must be rigorously defined but other
than that it can be
described in by various means and
natural process that we will see is one
of the examples
so and let me now
put here my favorites one of my favorite
sentences
be careful sir well you do algorithms
you do
whatever you prove crms and when you
cannot do something then you
start to explain others why you are
so stupid answer as you see here
this principle was not invented by
complexity theorists
but still that's basically what we are
going to do in this talk
as i said it's highly speculative so let
me
and uh yes i forgot to say
that uh we will be it will be one of our
guiding principles is that
we will be interested in our pro systems
again broadly understood for which even
that
statement is supposed to be heard
so on there in those four systems in
which you can first
formulate this statement and
seconds uh this blue word anya
does not make your life any simpler
so proving that np is not in p slash
product is supposed to be
more or less as hard as following it for
any boolean functions
let me briefly state a few motivations
right
so first of all because mathematicians
do it
we know great independence result in
mathematical logic of choice continuum
hypothesis or
the other's incompleteness theorem and
itself explaining that it is interesting
the second motivation
it actually started in the book by gary
johnson 79
of 79 in there as many of you know
in the first chapters they carefully
laid
down this principle
that are the theory of np completeness
is good for many reasons
but one of them is that you can explain
to your boss
why you cannot do the job so that's the
second version
the third reason are it is of course uh
because uh since this problem
so far mathematics never gave up
on its problems it kept solving them
if necessary for centuries and as we
know eventually they get solved
so we have to continue and so like in
complexities here
computational complexities here i mean
it is the same hole
we are going to focus
our research in the right direction
by just
saying what and why does not work so
it's uh the ideology that we used in our
paper
on natural pearls of course uh well
as we as stephen and me had expected
everyone misused that sentence
and stood the paper like blue circuit
lower bounds do something else
well we cannot do anything about it it
was not our intention our intention was
just that we showed what does not work
and so let's take it from there
and the third but also import
force i'm sorry but also very important
uh motivation is occurs about byproducts
so again that's what complex this year
is about
you approve something totally useless
and then
something comes out of it that made the
difference in the real world
even if you did not even think about it
the same sort of happens in this
business as well
all right so what's next so
uh diagonalization uh
it was the first it probably was the
first barrier
let me go over this slide very quickly
so it's a pro system in my sense right
so if you have a complexity result
then the pro system it simply says that
it should be true in all oracle worlds
it's well defined it's not of course
like the usual power system
but still it is rigorously defined and
we all know this classical scenario by
baker gil and salary
is that this pro system is not capable
of drawing or growing
its rpe is equal to np or its complement
that's uh probably the first
manifestation
that was probably the first
manifestation of this idea that approved
system is not necessarily
rules and axioms in first order logic
it might be something else but something
reasonable
so what does it mean to be reasonable
again let me try so four
will be a magic number for some reasons
throughout my talk let me formulate four
constraints and fish list
that i would like to have in a
uh in a framework that a barrier or
process or whatever you like
to study this kind of things these kind
of things i mean
so the first of course uh is
that uh your system should not be able
to solve this creation in the obvious
way by
counting and it rules out throwing proof
systems like
like tools well are shy i probably will
disagree with this
but we will or we will listen to what he
can say
uh in an hour about a stronger
consistency
so that's uh for 40 purpose of my talk i
really don't want to be
i really don't want shannon arguments to
be formalizable
in my proof system there because it's
it's not an interesting move i want i
want it to be out
so the seconds are which is
very important are very important is
that if you take your favorite result in
circuit complexity
and we do have a few results as you know
and so by the way it is an excellent
book one of the best books i've ever
seen
so if you take any result from this book
then
you really don't want to work hard
on uh proving it in your system
you don't you don't want to write papers
you don't want to introduce
something some new concepts you just
take it and it should be
doable in your system in a
straightforward way
so and returning to my accounting
scheme turns out that now all
those results are well exactly occurs
from that book
exactly of course for the chapter that
talks about
shannon accounting arguments and lupanos
improvements
all other results they use only counting
up or polynomial in the number of
instances
so little n of course stays everywhere
for the number of variables so it is
just polynomial in the number of your
instances
so all those are all those problems they
use counting
only after this number which is single
exponential
right so this work is self explaining
we are really one proof system that
people care about
and sages are probably the weakest
points
or the weakest point of natural proofs
because somehow that's what we cooked up
i will show you what what we did
in several slides so
butts are still we have some motivations
but
other than that usually it should be
natural the whole system should be
somehow of interest i cannot quantify it
and of course the first
thing is that we really want to hope to
make
progress so and in logic
you make progress if
usually if meta mathematics of your
problem system
so what you can extract from growth
basically it's uh
somehow matches mathematics so the other
thing is theorem it is
metamastermatics is a formula
that you prove you import them and then
it is the same semantics about integers
your whole system is arguing about
and if it looks uh very if it looks
abstract uh so you'll then
let me point out this recent
breakthrough
result by albert and mueller alberta
series and lunar
they proved something extremely concrete
improved complexity not all the extreme
american can create or
automatize a period of resolution but
but what has been open for decades and
they really use this self-referring
argument
so it's not if you are interested in can
create things then you are still
you still want to hear it right here shy
again grover disagrees with this
we are going to listen sweetly
all right so let me remind you uh what
are
natural rules and i will be very quick
uh because uh this book is about
something relevant
but still something else so
uh these are two pieces of common wisdom
so uh the first one is that if you want
to prove laura bounce reborn functions
and you should look at how it looks like
study its properties and then move it to
lower bounds
and the second piece of wisdom it says
that if you want to analyze your
problems then you should carefully look
into them
do a roof system and blah blah blah so
the starting point of natural process is
that we dismiss both
both of them so namely
instead of even trying to understand
what our group looks like
so we are going to think about it
sometimes creatively
it's uh sometimes it's not
straightforward and
then we are going to conclude that
the same argument can be applied not
only to your function of
interest but through aggregates a deal
of other functions which
[Music]
which gives rise to the set of boolean
functions
pm to which your argument can be applied
in a sense
and so that's the only thing we need in
our
uh we need in our model so
we only look at this set pm and
then we formulize formalize
so for hppn so in
right sorry pm and cn on this slide
are the same so and then we simply
write the properties of this
uh set of functions first of all of
course
we wanted to make sense and the second
two properties
they are debatable but still that's
what happens in our all or almost all
known proofs and
you really want to understand what you
are doing
so which means that our set pn
must be computable or in polynomial time
in this quantity
and it must have large density
so once you have a good method then you
really are going to be able to apply it
to
sufficiently many functions usually it
is even
better than that usually it is just
almost all fractures but to be on the
safe side
so let us share against
our four items from the wish list
there is no obvious counting solution
you cannot count that's why we have here
constructiveness right so if you count
up for
larger than that number then it will not
be
in polynomial time
so that is what we call
naturalization so
there are some technicalities which are
monotone formulas or basically because
it is not so easy to define
goods or distribution over
the good distribution over monotone
formulas but more you can do it
so as i said this is this is the weak
point of natural groups
so you can prove but here is at least
one justification for it which is also
alone
that's uh it's written here
if you approach the famous card and your
pro system is
closed for explore then you'll somehow
and you understand what you are going
then you should be able to tell which
one of these stories hurt and it gives
you largeness because
you have then half of all functions
and here
uh on the fourth era item about
mathematics versus meta mathematics
uh it looks so it is almost here because
our one of our actions it has polynomial
inside of it and we study uh
right short circuits small circuits but
so the glitch here
of course is uh is it really a problem
that
now we have changed our measure that
it's not
small and that it is true to different
is it really a problem well
uh turns out it is the main
and actually the only problem about
natural products is that
you really can prove things even in this
form
so that's the main theorem of natural
proof so modular
standards cryptographic assumptions
there is no natural profit against
generous circuits self-defeating
arguments in its price
good so as i said
there is lots of work on natural proofs
and
people disagree with many of these
points
some people agree some people both agree
and disagree at the same time
and let me stop it here
so and this is uh this is one
very important byproduct so uh
it says sir it will be the same
throughout my whole talk
that we actually are interested in
our inputs we are measuring our main
uh size measure is this capital
m it will always be the same which is
the number of instances in my problem
which means that your
boolean functions are given as true
stable
and one by-product is
that this work
with simulation highlighted the
importance of this problem
which these days is called minimum
circuit size problem
which is here it is obvious it is the
set of
all false tables or the corresponds to
simple functions and let me just
say that there has been a lot of
very interesting and wonderful and
important research on this problem and
somehow our paper helped to understand
its importance and that it is a really
good thing to study
so in complexity terms if we forget
about all
our motivations then in complexity terms
natural which occurs can be easily
formulated in terms of
this this problem as
as is written here
right so that's it with natural curves
let's move on and uh
so these are the two points i repeat
here at the two points
that's natural approach this means today
in the in the remaining of my time today
we are going
uh so now so still dismiss the first
point
as i said we are interested in approve
systems
that actually do not distinguish between
explicit functions and any functions but
we want to replace the second
second point with its opposite
so the really wants are good persistence
in in the good old sense of formal
series and of course as antonin
already said there is lots of work about
it so
here i really wants to say
just for just a bit so bound guitar
arithmetic is just piano
arithmetic where you focus on bounded
quantifiers
bounded by terms so you also have
sharpie about the quantifiers
and it is important that it is just a
normal
first order theory
slow no edges axioms
inference rules so again
as almost all of you or all of you know
are as one is the most important
theory in the whole family there is a
higher record there is a fairly
hierarchical it closely models
her complexity hierarchy but
i don't have much time today so i will
talk only about s21
and the fourth item
in my wish list it is answered by this
fundamental theorem by symbols
but it's it's uh from his book about
boundaries metrics that basically
started
this whole subject is that if you prove
something existential in this theorem
and a
is a simple simple indicated then
you have a well you know then it can be
witnessed by polynomial time
function so here we see here polynomial
time
that corresponds to meta mathematics of
our approach system
and so it's the same concept we are
going to study
therefore it's good news for us
so sorry it should be s1 s21 reversed
so now are the game
it's a it's a shorter version of the
talk i have to skip many details
that i gave before and
but you can formalize the creation we
are interested in
so here our reports are sub-exponential
function to avoid circuitry realities
and this is the equation
whether we can prove the existence of a
boolean function a friend
so
right there is no obvious counting
solution because we don't know
the answer to this question we don't
know whether whether
it is probable or not therefore there
are no
counting solutions obvious counting
solutions
this is uh the second part is
also very easy and very natural so if
you look at the same statements but for
for restricted circuit models then
you can really do it in this system
it is extremely straightforward so
i did it once and mostly i focused on
the question
or are there weaker systems
than this where you can prove all that
stuff
from or status book and
yeah and so it is very natural
very simple so uh
of course bug nutrition that's what we
love
for many good reasons it's not only
because
we are able to do this stuff and
now comes now comes an interesting part
so that i will show on the next slide
and
it's good that i was able to get to that
slide
so but one clarification is that
we cannot hold to get to all the way
up to this body arithmetic
unconditionally
so i like in natural probes i do allow
your arbitrary
reasonable complexity cryptographic
assumptions that are short of
our np is not equal to coin p because
that makes the whole game trivial
so again uh it's a short version let me
just mention a competing framework
which was uh
which is promoted by yankovic
so in this framework you allow even more
restricted counting
you cannot really call count up to
capital m
but on the other hand it's no longer
simple existential formulas you allow
lots of quantifiers
it's very interesting framework or
connected in many respects
to what i'm talking about here but i
don't have time to
uh talk about it
so in now again it's it will be s21
so and now we can reformulate or
the equations we are interested in in
terms of
prepositional group complexity because
again
there is a cage here due to sharply
pointed quantifiers
but more examples theorem almost
implies that or if you prove
this in s21 then should be there should
be some explicit sequence
of functions for which you can prove the
same thing
and once you have a quantifier free
statements or only sharply about the 25
then
25 then you can translate it to
prepositional proof complexity
propositional logic you can express it
as a prepositional formula
the fact that the function frame is part
and
the size of this formula again where
use our convention or our main principle
that we don't care how we encode it it's
simply given by its roots table we have
enough
memory or enough time to just import
it as a rules table and measure
everything as a polynomial in terms of
the length
and now comes the main slide
so uh we have now we have this
square namely
we have frozen bounded arithmetic
and it shares very popular
topic connections between bounded
arithmetic and uniform complexity
classes
are given by various fitness
same exteriors here and was the first
scenario from this family if you if you
if you have something in boundaries
particular
compound it's arithmetic as to one then
you get
something pretty normally time
computable so
if you have sigma if you have delta zero
will be a quantifier free
formulas then you can
[Music]
translate them through propositional
systems
and so this will give your you will just
work in now in more much more convenient
and more elegant prepositional
uh world for example s21
again s21 is different s21
gets translated so extend it for again
so this is also this connection is
very
is standard in computational complexity
so every
uniform complexity class essentially
every uniform complexity class you have
a saturated
non-uniform class so what we really need
is
the force arrow
right so you would really expect a force
error on this picture i give you a
propositional proof
it argues about computational concepts
and you want to extract
some computation something computational
out of it
and then apply your knowledge like we
did in natural proofs or
in our in this implication apply our
knowledge to get conditional results
and it's embarrassing that we almost
cannot do it
and i don't understand why
right so let me
uh give you a few definitions for
example systems
resolution extended regular system well
i believe that
everyone knows what it is so i have only
less of the means left i don't want to
spend time here
all right so the success story and it is
precisely a model case of
what we would like to have idea
is called feasible interpolation that's
precisely what we
what we would love to have so i give
your
special special apology and it all
it all is applied here and
then you ask and
then you extract from it something
computational which is called feasible
interpolation
so you can apply it to several systems
of interests
but then it turns out
that you cannot go very far along these
lines
because uh simply
feasible interpolation are fails for
more uh
for for stronger systems for systems
that we are really interested in
well i mean we are interested in all
those systems
as well as everyone in this workshop
already knows by
this time but for different reasons
so here is a byproduct of this
one by product of this or it is simply
because it is simply one
uh quite amazing thing about rock
complexity is that
really it is the same phenomenon
unlike circuit complex if you really
don't know if there
are any car tautologies for regular or
extended regular systems
there is no accounting argument here so
in this paper
they tried to come up with some with
some
examples but uh i guess they indicated
themselves
that it was not very conclusive and most
of those results were
are solved i mean are short rules
infrared origin regular found
later on the principle is that these
systems are really hard
so we really want some arguments that we
don't understand
ourselves and at the moment i
have owned it law and i think everyone
has only so a reasonably convincing
example so what might be hard
for greg or excellent fragrance the
first is random cnns
it's just because you you don't
understand why
or if you pick a random cnf why is it
unsatisfiable you have to count for
for that and so it's beyond the reach of
our system and it
is the second example is coming from
this business or proving that
npa is a mod equal is not in p slash
party
uh it is uh the second
candidate cards topology and it is
a game which is uh we don't understand
it's
to the extent that we don't even know if
it is true or not
which makes it perfect
so uh i have only a few minutes left
so let me very briefly say that we have
some ad hoc results for uh
[Music]
so that's now what we are going to study
we are going to
try to understand why this thing is uh
difficult for various
verb traditional systems we have a few
unconditional results
and it also does not go quite far
so and so that's basically the last
thing i want to
show and uh do you have five minutes
after why not
so and so that's uh one suggestion
that uh is uh still
which which made it anywhere so
[Music]
improve all this other stuff to stronger
systems
so let me start with reminding you about
natural house
and the way you provide it is that you
construct
pseudo-random function generator if you
have an ordinary
one-way function then you get an
ordinary
child random bit generator out of it and
you can either construct it
using general construction by mikali
goldwasser and rakoff
or you can take for example missile
deter something immediately gives you a
conjectural
function generator and so this is
basically the whole proof
you have to supply fewer details
so the idea is to try to understand
what it looks or what it might look like
in the prepositional world so again i
have a mapping
i have a pro system p so uh
our idea was that if i give you nissan
vectors on generator
or any other generator
another reasonable generator and i i
give you identically zero string
right and i ask you is it is it true or
not that
this string is not in the image of your
generator is not generated by any seed
then it's really impossible to do
so if your generator is reasonable then
you cannot answer
this basic question you cannot really
pinpoint any
particular strain in the image of the
generator that
is
not in the domain of your
generator that is not in the image and
that's what we take as a definition
of our hardness
so the idea is of course that we can use
so if i give you any string b then your
system does not prove that b is not in
the image of this
so answer the proposal is simply
well the proposal is simply to try to
somehow uh right shield item generators
is something that is well studied income
interpretation complexity
and so the proposal is of course so
search for this missing force narrow
using maybe
at least as in as as our inspirations
what is low in the computational world
so in a sense good news is that it's or
it extends
feasible interpolation so if you have
physical integration for your system
then you basically can
do it with a slight twist of your
generator
and this is the main conjecture
is that if you take
any nissan literature generator just for
simplicity and for concreteness and you
base it on any function
then or it becomes hard for exchange
regular system
so that was made almost 20 years ago
there has been some work
but not much on it and it is still wide
open and basically i would like people
that was the main purpose one of the
main purposes of my talk is to draw
attention
to this architecture so here
is what we know we don't know very much
so we know this conjecture for reads
resolution rates
for polynomial characters
for even even for resolution it is
frustrating
because we don't know it for
exponentially
many output bits only on the n squared
and so it is a very important work by
young rajcik
so which is again the same principle you
can iterate
this generator so as you do in our
circuit complexity and for example for
resolution you can get slightly better
you can get to cube
and so that's probably the best you can
do
at the moment it is the proof system
where you can
lift this stuff so our jedi random
generator for this system well i hope
you know what it is it is it's a strong
key system for which
will be in all these stages so and
as i mentioned several times there are
many other suggestions
so often the the obvious open problem so
it should stay as to one it is or just
the same
yr as ue isomorphism tonya mentioned
before
so it is the main conjecture again
it is connected to models here somehow
so now we have
had several breaks or results in cutting
planes in
several last years but as far as i know
they formally don't imply unconditional
hardness
of this statement that it would be a
great problem accessible problems
or accessible problem i mean well unless
i missed something and there is a simple
reduction
which i don't see so perfectly is for
its hardness for cutting planes or
sum of squares as far as i know it is
open
unconditionally conditionally you can
apply feasible interpolation
and so the same equation for bounded
depths fragment
we missed some techniques basically or
random orientations where
not suited very very well for the task
but
these people they explained to us that
it is much more
versatile method than we had thought
about it
so again even for resolution we have
to apply other methods if you don't have
pseudo-random generator for resolution
that that is really in the range we are
interested in
and it's very loose because yeah it's
variables creation
right
thank you so much this is fantastic this
is such an inspiring talk i'll clap for
everybody
questions comments
peace i have a question
so you you motivated the the search for
natural proof by
you didn't want to have counting up to
doubly exponential
but that can be then you could have said
that the proof should be of exponential
length so
the proof should be in p space um
why not take a simpler definition of
natural
uh no uh it's sir
so no our each user it is not uh
what we want to achieve it's uh i view
it as a chest for what
what we are doing is right it's sanity
check
i do it only at the same teacher it's
not like i
really it's it's not my purpose but
simply if your system be it natural
approach or anything else if it does not
pass just check that it means that
it's the game or it's not
what you're it's not interested
problem it's not the purpose but sir
it's
excellent okay thanks
more questions like if i can ask a
question
you ended with a comment about lifting
versus
natural proofs so i was wondering if you
think there's any connection between the
two
and the techniques or the approaches
i think it's more again i had
to revise which means
vandalize my large stock
fitted here right
so in the long version it refers only to
this result
okay so our natural proofs or
so it's our it comes it comes here in
this business or if you
uh have a system with physical
interpolation right
and you want absurd random natural
pseudorandom generator
then you'll go very primitively
extremely primitive
but still you're doing it
these are either is there anything like
that for natural pros or promoter
systems
it's a it's very limited question
okay
such as in this diagram that you have on
the slides
so you were asking about the arrow on
the bottom
so your proposal is to to use these
tau formulas uh this formula is saying
that something is not in the image of
a pseudorandom generator
this should be the arrow down it's sir
it's small possibility
so and so it's it's main is it is it
your conjecture
or that this is the right arrow or you
suggest it is one possibility or
this conjecture is made or in my
animal's paper
it's so it's quite official
[Music]
or are you asking her in the reverse
direction
so if you know i'm asking whether this
you propose this as the solution of what
the arrow should be so i know that you
propose this conjecture but
do you propose this as
the only solution of this arrow or
well well this solution cares
extremely uh well maybe a bit dirty but
extremely powerful
something extremely powerful behind it
might be a bad
it might be totally incorrect but you
don't have any signals
[Music]
at least i am not aware of anything that
i would recognize
as a project as a plan so to get it
right right blah
i had tried lots of things and
but it's very frustrating you have an
object right which is essentially
a sequence of circuits for everyone else
i circuits everyone computes
each one of these circuits computes one
because it's a tautology and he wants to
get some computational
content out of it and you fail
i don't i don't understand why even in
30 years i guess
i still don't understand why they failed
so each essay which is simply it's a
it's a it's like
democracy i would compare this or
to driving generators with democracy it
may be a bad system it might be a lousy
system but it's better
than anything else
um i i have a quick question so you were
talking about
s1 2 as kind of the right system the
right power to
talk about complexity but in recent
years people have
been working with um victims
that formalized probabilistic reasoning
apc1 and friends what do you think about
about that um it is
first of all it is definitely
a very interesting line of research
and i certainly don't want to say
anything negative about it but
somehow i feel that
you mean this one right
somehow i
don't feel quite strongly
in terms of this thing
it's uh it's uh it looks like
this systems they
in many cases they were somehow
so formalize or capture particular
things it's not the case with valid
arithmetic right
here charismatic was not invented so or
something analyzed it was we wanted to
capture phenomenal time
it's not with piano is not the case with
an piano all finite arguments some
politics systems
i'm not sure that they
whatever thank you thank you so much
so more questions comments
can you uh um go back to the slide where
you have this
generator that you talk about
what's from sorry the nissan victorson
generator
uh the first time that you talked about
it well no it's not brackets
yes yeah yeah this one
so can you go back one slide
uh the one where you have the mapping
from
uh functions yeah this one what exactly
what exactly are you saying here so i'm
just trying to understand this so i'm
saying
i'm saying that uh if if you take
any a reasonable generator for example
nissan vinderson right
and i ask your equation like i give you
identical is here or
almost all strings here are not in the
image of this generator
yes yeah if i if i if if i am
asking whether identically zero string
is in the image of this generator or not
you will not be able to answer this
question
regardless of any proof complexity
just fix it or in any reasonable way of
course you can always manually
you can manually ensure that it is not
there but if you don't
play any tricks then you will not be
answered you will
be able to answer this question about
identically zero string
okay thanks
and we simply analyze it for all other
streams
great well thank you so much this is
fantastic